they are often reduced to just being  a body seen as something that could be  easily discarded  they're just asking for dignity which  you would think all of us would want  james baldwin to say to be a negro in  this country  and to be relatively conscious means  that you are enraged  almost all the time  [Music]  you realize you live in a world where  your humanity is constantly being  questioned  this country needs to put the mirror up  we're angry because of the notion that  we love our community we love our black  boys and all black girls  these young people don't need savings  they need believers  we're passing this stuff on from  generation to generation we're  better than what black people and black  males are experiencing  we are better than that  you